Russia shares this big,
long border with Finland.
And Finland
just joined NATO,
the Western military alliance.
They’re also about to let American troops
come to Finland.
And Russia does not like this.
So as a response,
they have been sending migrants
from like war zones
that are looking for asylum
and safety to this border.
And they're putting them on bicycles.
And they have nowhere to go
but into Finland.
Now, Russia knows that
Finland is required
to let these asylum seekers in,
and the hope here is that
this flood of migrants will create
discord and division
within Finnish society
and will make them angry
at this decision to join NATO
or to let U.S.
troops in.
Putin is using these migrants
as a weapon in his hybrid warfare
against the West.
So in response,
Finland actually closed
these land border crossings.
And so now you have this
terrible situation of migrants
just sitting there,
not able to go anywhere
in these terrible conditions.
If you want to better understand
global politics, follow along for more.